merci beaucoup
allez-y installé vous monsieur Corbière
je vous en prie merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous Alexis Corbière d'être notre
invité politique ce matin député
savez-vous même député la France
insoumise de la Seine-Saint-Denis en
étant ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représentée par
Stéphane Vernet de Ouest-France bonjour
Stéphane bonjour bonjour
on commence en parlant de la question de
l'immigration Alexis Corbière hier
invitée du 20h de TF1 Gérald Darmanin
indique la France n'accueillera pas de
migrants venus de Lampedusa comment vous
réagissez à ce message de fermeté
politique démagogique d'un certain point
de vue
n'étant pas responsable le problème
c'est bien sûr qu'il y a une situation
difficile chaotique dans certains
endroits mais le droit d'asile ça existe
face à des situations de crise je
voudrais rappeler que c'est quoi le fond
du problème en vérité c'est
effectivement à partir du moment où on
organisons rien ou le l'accueil de tous
ces gens qui fuient leur pays il
faudrait s'interroger pour quelles
raisons les gens fuient leur pays et
essayer de résoudre ce problème là le
problème est extrêmement complexe mais
s'interroger pourquoi des traités de
libre-échange parfois en fichu en l'air
des certaines économies des dérèglements
climatiques des problèmes politiques bon
mais après juste une chose même si
l'argument a déjà été dit nous venons
d'accueillir en niveau européen en
raison de la guerre Ukraine 8 millions
de personnes dont 106.000 110 000 en
France avec droit logement droit à
l'éducation droit à la santé et à partir
du moment les choses ont été organisées
je ne crois pas qu'il y ait eu ici ou là
d'incidents particuliers ce que je veux
dire c'est un pays en guerre Gérald
Darmanin il dit on accueille pas de
migrants mais on accueillera ses devoir
de la France des personnes qui sont en
danger dans leur pays d'accord mais
enfin je me suis Darmanin à l'heure où
il a fait le plateau de TF1 hier soir ne
connaît pas tout à fait la nationalité
des gens mais on qui sont en lampe 12
hommes on peut imaginer beaucoup
viennent de Syrie ou de pays dans lequel
la situation politique ou économique est
extrêmement chaotique donc une fois que
l'Italie aura examiné les cas la France
accueillera s'il s'agit de réfugier
notamment de réfugiés politiques oui
mais il y a une situation il y a une
qu'est-ce qu'il aurait dû dire pour vous
il aurait dû dire que de toute manière
nous devons prendre en charge
mais au niveau international ce
phénomène qui est celui du fait que des
gens risquent leur vie quittent leur
pays voilà je dirais le nombre de morts
en Méditerranée est insupportable toute
conscience qu'elle soit politique
humaniste spirituelle même le pape
auquel quel est le sang voilà moi je
me suis élevé contre la présence
d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce qu'elle était
président de la République qui va
participer à la messe du pape à
Marseille parce que je pense que une
bonne compréhension de la laïcité doit
amener à ce que cet acte politique est
inutile et n'a pas été fait en réalité
par ses prédécesseurs mais s'il y va
c'est sans doute qu'il veut entendre le
message qu'à ce que le pape François a
dire est précisément sur ce sujet ce que
ce que dit cette autorité religieuse
tout à fait respectable c'est que nous
devons avoir notre devoir d'humanité et
d'accueil donc vous y voyez une forme de
contradiction ah bah c'est le moment
qu'on puisse dire je veux dire c'est
quoi le sujet alors pour quelle raison
alors là j'ai abordé un autre sujet pour
quelle raison piétiner la laïcité donner
une impression que c'est la géométrie
quand une autorité religieuse vient je
vais l'écouter mais je ne le fais pas
pour d'autres mais si en plus c'est pour
l'écouter et ne même pas et ne rien
retenir de son message c'est quoi c'est
pour faire se prendre en photo et
instrumentaliser si je puis dire la
venue d'une personnalité pour dire les
yeux mi-clos je me je je m'en prends je
suis tout entier habité par ce message
de fraternité et ne rien en faire et
envoyer monsieur Darmanin qu'est-ce
qu'il fait Darmanin il est uniquement
dans un rapport électoral vis-à-vis de
l'extrême droite où il croit qu'il va
siphonner les voix du Front national en
parlant comme le Front national
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
le problème vous pouvez bâtir toutes les
forteresses que vous voulez tous les
barbelés que vous voulez vous voulez
même mobiliser l'armée française sur les
côtes de France le phénomène qui est en
train de t'avoir à lui est un phénomène
politique économique profond auquel nous
devons réfléchir et toutes les postures
d'armanesse ne règleront rien des gens
se mettront en danger de mort donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait donc je dédie pas
évidemment c'est le moment de dire la
France va accueillir c'est le sujet
arrêtons c'est c'est débilité maintenant
nous devons prendre notre part pour ce
problème là ça veut dire quoi pour notre
part organiser certaines choses
l'organiser au niveau international voir
comment je le répète pourquoi des gens
qui te leur pays évitez qu'il le
quittent je veux dire personne n'a envie
de quitter son village à Attal sa ville
natale etc donc si on ne résout rien de
ces problèmes-là voire même parfois on
les accélère bon ben Emmanuel Macron il
dit pas autre chose il dit aussi qu'il
faut aider des CPI qu'il faut les aider
financièrement qu'il faut aider leur
développement de tout ça pour quelle
raison les choses continuent d'accord
pourquoi
interrogons-nous pourquoi les traiter de
libre-échange continuent pourquoi le
dérèglement climatique continue et que
la France même et condamné pour non non
action donc je veux dire sortons de tout
ça et le problème une fois de plus ne se
réglera pas là c'est un problème long
mais prenons la mesure et arrêtons de
courir derrière l'extrême droite parce
que au bout d'un moment de vouloir son
électorat c'est l'extrême droite qui
vous siphonne complètement à l'inverse
quand Jean-Luc Mélenchon dit dimanche
quand il promet une vague de
régularisation mas des sans-papiers s'il
venait à gouverner ce qu'il a dit vous
êtes sur la même longueur d'onde vous
êtes aussi catégorique que lui sur le
sujet sur ce qui travaille sur ce que
vous voulez qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
tous ceux qui travaillent c'est ce qui
est dans notre programme les gens qui
travaillent qui occupent une activité
professionnelle en vérité doivent être
régularisés j'en connais énormément dans
ma circonscription des mamans qui sont
des mers d'élèves de la classe de ma
fille sont des femmes de ménage qui
travaillent etc qui vivent qui sont là
depuis des années qui occupe des
logements qui payent leur loyer etc tu
sais que cette histoire n'est maintenant
dans une forme de précarité donc il faut
la régularisation et les politiques de
séjour en tout cas des travailleurs qui
sont déjà présents sur notre salle
pourquoi les préfectures ne le font pas
déjà ça je elles peuvent le faire en
vérité si ce que vous dites était vrai
que je suis verrez beaucoup de ces
activités soulagées parce que beaucoup
de gens viennent nous voir donc pour ne
serait-ce qu'obtenir un rendez-vous en
préfecture au sein de Saint-Denis à ceux
qui les phrases heures qui n'y
connaissent rien qui croient dans ce
pays suffit d'arriver pour avoir des
papiers ne savent pas les files
d'attentes qui existent devant des
préfectures
indécent des gens qui passent la nuit là
aujourd'hui la dématérialisation de tout
ça qui fait que des gens n'y arrivent
pas moi j'avais même demandé j'ai fait
une commission d'enquête sur le fait
qu'il y a même un marché un marché noir
de vente de bon tout ça et scandale
migration la possibilité les titres de
séjour pour les travailleurs sans
papiers dans les métiers en tension
est-ce que si ça figure bien dans ce
texte vous le voterez ce texte que nous
dit ce texte c'est que ce qu'il veut
c'est pour certains métiers c'est-à-dire
le patronat déciderait selon des
critères en plus qui restent discutables
tous les qu'est-ce qu'on appelle un
métier dit en tension etc beaucoup de
gens par ailleurs j'observe sont parfois
dans tous ces métiers
ubérisés de livraison qui n'est pas
considéré comme un métier en tension et
il y a énormément de gens en situation
irrégulière actuelle et pourtant c'est
un travail dur en risquant leur vie dans
des conditions de rémunération qui sont
pas descentes monsieur Darmanin lui veut
faire là aussi une espèce de pondération
par rapport à un texte qu'il a encore
après le Front national en disant cette
fois-ci des au qtf ça va être séance
tenante alors que on arrive à peine à
agir sur 10% parce que c'est quasiment
impossible c'est discuter vous ne
voterez pas le texte même si la
régularités de figure après dans un
débat on va voir a priori je ne suis pas
pour que ce soit pris sous la forme d'un
corps d'un travailleur jetable qui
pendant un moment reste sous pression
d'une menace que si tu travailles pas
bien dans quelques mois tu n'auras pas à
nouveau ton papier parce que le monde
gentillet ça n'est pas comme ça il y a
des employeurs aussi qui peuvent
profiter de cette situation pour dire à
un salarié écoute je vais t'obtenir ton
titre de 12 mois maintenant tu vas
fermer ta bouche quand éventuellement
syndical il vient te dire que tu es mal
payé tu vas te tu vas aller te mettre un
peu de côté quand l'inspecteur du
travail va venir parce que peut-être
qu'on respecte pas complètement les
choses je n'incrimine pas les patrons
mais je connais la réalité du monde du
travail ce que demande le mouvement
syndical c'est qu'au minimum soit des
régularisations de deux à quatre ans
pour que les gens aient un peu de
visibilité parce que je peux pas sur ce
texte vous ne fermez pas la porte à un
vote de ce texte ou vous dites
attendez que ce que soit clair c'est le
29e texte je crois en l'espace de un peu
plus d'une trentaine d'années
c'est-à-dire que à force je suis pas un
vieux parlementaire mais je commence
déjà à avoir vu quelques-uns et ceux qui
vous qui observez ça le nombre de fois
où un ministre vient pétaradent garde à
vous bonbons le temps montait arrêtons
tout ça alimente qu'une conversation
alors que la conversation en cette
rentrée elle est sociale sur l'inflation
sur les pieds
une conversation sur les immigrés tu les
aimes comment tu as quelle température
j'en dois un expulser combien cette
discussion franchement ne fait que
nourrir un agenda d'extrême droite
idéologique alors que la question elle
est sociale elle est démocratique on va
parler de l'inflation inflation est-ce
que vous voterez le texte sur le sur la
vente à perte cette pression mise sur
les entreprises les appelant à rogner
leur marge est-ce que c'est une bonne
chose non c'est pas une bonne chose on
n'arrête pas de faire il faut bloquer
les prix et les marges qui notamment des
grands groupes pétroliers qui par
ailleurs répercutent qui qui font des
profits significatifs le bon ça a été
dit mille fois là en réaction va être
tout de même ce serait paradoxal que on
se retrouve dans une situation où la
grande distribution qui peut vendre à la
personne c'est même pas sûr qu'elle le
fasse d'ailleurs se retrouve en
continuant à faire une petite une
augmentation enfin un bon coup j'ai
envie de dire et qu'on se retrouve avec
tout un réseau de station-service qui
doit fermer la porte
mais je veux dire ça ne va pas marcher
c'est pas de l'argent public
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a du profit privé
qui est réalisé par un effet d'aubaine
le le pétrole c'est les distributeurs de
pétrole aujourd'hui qui qui font
augmenter le prix du baril mais il y a
une marge plus importante on ne va rien
on ne va rien toucher à la marge les
dividendes vont continuer à augmenter et
c'est l'argent public qui va venir
éventuellement compenser tout ça mais
enfin pour quelle raison donc vous votez
pastèque bah il est absurde je veux dire
que j'invite madame borne à écouter ce
que nous disons blocage des prix et des
marges ça c'est compréhensible et de
grâce n'étranglons pas le réseau qui en
province parfois est indispensable
dépistations services voilà ça me semble
être une bonne politique de faire ça sur
la transition
écologique tout à l'heure mais manuel
Bompard a boycotter les réunions de la
réunion des parties à Matignon lundi sur
la planification écologique il estime
que les débats politiques doivent avoir
lieu dans les assemblées parlementaires
vous vous partagez l'idée vous aussi
j'espère sinon il faut fermer la chaîne
au bout d'un moment je vais vous dire
une chose il n'y a pas un moment où il y
a pas il y a pas d'autres lieux vous
pouvez trouver des des endroits où vous
pouvez négocier avec le avec le
gouvernement vous êtes en blocage
systématique surtout vous êtes d'accord
que votre question porte un elle-même le
fait que quelqu'un là je parle de la
première indice utilise le 49-3 qui ne
veut pas discuter avec des
parlementaires dans il faudrait valider
un fonctionnement qui est je vais dire
clairement anti républicain et voir même
qui est une démocratie de base intensité
c'est quoi le sujet c'est quoi le sujet
auquel on a assisté c'est que on a eu
une grande conversation l'année dernière
sur la question des retraites tout un
pays a dit non franchement toutes les
études d'opinion démontré qu'ils les
Français y étaient opposés à 73 % voire
même 93% pour ce qui est des actifs
l'ensemble des forfaits de la majorité
des forces politiques étaient aussi la
tel point qu'il n'y avait pas de
majorité à l'Assemblée moi je ne veux
pas banaliser l'utilisation du 49-3 par
dessus ça un président bloqué organise
une forme de nouveaux rendez-vous
politique qui tient plus de l'ancien
régime et des états généraux de Louis
XVI qui réunit les gens on va discuter
force politique et Sa Majesté après
retiendra certaines choses de la
conversation bon ce fonctionnement ami
qui m'écoutait n'est pas un
fonctionnement sain sur le plan
politique nous ne sommes pas là pour
être invités par le le monarque qui va
nous écouter un peu nous morigéner de
temps en temps donner son opinion et
finalement retenir certaines choses la
conversation
comme on
la vie politique s'ouvre d'un poison je
l'ai déjà dit ici le bonapartisme il
n'est pas possible qu'autant de pouvoir
se concentre sur un homme minoritaire
dans le pays donc il faut
reparlementariser la vie politique
revenir des choses simples le conflit
est inhérent à toute société nous
n'avons pas les mêmes idées la vie
démocratique doit s'organiser de manière
parlementaire tout ça est perfectible
après mais dans lequel il y a des
majorités il y a des minorités etc si on
court-circuit de tout ça si on vous met
des 49-3 dans le visage mais que quand
même parce que ça commence à se voir que
c'est brutal madame bornes nous invite
pour faire des conversations et
évidemment si au bout d'un moment nous
lui disons mais attendez ça n'est pas un
bon fonctionnement qu'on nous dit vous
n'êtes pas constructif bon tout ça est
un piège enfin je dirais et en plus
n'amène à rien donc Madame borne avec
tout le respect que je lui dois pour ça
au Sénat à l'Assemblée nulle part
ailleurs mais j'espère que tous les
parlementaires de ce pays tout efface
politique vont dire arrêtons ce jeu
absurde discutons dans des commissions
parlementaires à l'assemblée de ce qui
doit être débattu et nous ne sommes pas
là pour alimenter un argent
la même que celle que je suis en train
de dire j'ai vu les courriers que fait
Monsieur Olivier fort ou les autres
après il peut y avoir on peut juger du
degré de tactique est-ce qu'on y va pour
dire qu'on n'est pas content où est-ce
qu'on va même y aller on dit qu'on n'est
pas content c'est pas le problème de pas
content d'ailleurs j'ai tort de le dire
comme ça c'est de dire nous sommes dans
un moment de crise démocratique
extrêmement profond les gens savent
tiennent de manière très significative
aux élections il y a des gens dégoûtés
dans le pays il y a dysfonctionnement de
la vie politique il est temps passé à la
Sixième République de le faire
tranquillement que les citoyens et des
droits nouveaux des droits
d'intervention des droits de contrôle il
est temps d'en finir avec la toute
puissance du pouvoir du Président de la
République c'est absurde cela fabrique
aujourd'hui je le répète une montée
d'une tentation autoritaire dans le pays
notamment qui s'incarne en effort
politique et qui peut-être vont prendre
le pouvoir si l'on continue comme ça le
premier texte c'est la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
vous l'examinerez la semaine prochaine
ça suscite pas l'enthousiasme des
opposition c'est le moins qu'on puisse
bien compris des républicains est-ce que
si un 49-3 ça veut dire que vous
déposerez une notion de censure dans la
foulée c'est la logique des choses mais
je veux dire on en vient c'est la suite
de la conversation que je viens d'avoir
on va pas en plus maintenant vous dire
ah bon on vous frappe le visage mais
vous osez riposter quels sont les armes
parlementaires dans nos disposons donc
c'est la logique des choses évidemment
je veux dire le 49-3 devrait être aboli
interdit ce n'est pas possible moi je ne
suis pas favorable je veux dire on a
banalisé ça mais je veux le prendre
positivement nos concitoyens sur les
marchés Seine-Saint-Denis montant
libanais la ville dans suit il me parle
49-3 articles 40 les gens se sont je
veux dire ont appris sur le plan
constitutionnel et si qu'est-ce que
c'est que cette constitution on peut
imposer des choses on peut bloquer des
débats on peut bon tout ça est très
concret on avait voté dans le précédent
budget je crois près de 12 milliards
pour le l'isolation thermique des
appartements etc bon quand tu as 49-3 ça
veut dire que même ce que le le
l'Assemblée nationale a décidé de mettre
dans le budget était facile alors qu'on
a vu cet été avec la canicule qui nous
arrive que nous allons avoir besoin je
veux dire très concret les 49-3 c'est
revenir supprimer des choses que la
majorité parlementaire a décidé on
parlait des sénatoriales c'est dimanche
la France insoumise qui n'a aucun
sénateur à l'heure actuelle a choisi de
présenter des candidats partout faute
d'accord avec vos alliés de gauche
est-ce que c'est pas contradictoire de
prôner l'Union et de pratiquer la
division
je crois que nos partenaires ont fait
une erreur de ne pas arriver à créer les
conditions que la nupais soit présente
aussi à l'occasion des élections
sénatoriales donc
là vous risquez de faire faire des
sièges à la gauche présentant
écologiste et je crois que certains même
le regrettent un peu c'est la vie ont
essayé par le jeu très compliqué du
Sénat qui est un jeu tordu je veux pas
dire que c'est une aberration
démocratique mais Thomas le
fonctionnement de désignation des
candidats est un peu curieuse tellement
pardon oui bien sûr non mais moi je suis
pas un ardent défenseur du Sénat et de
ce monde de fonctionnement des grands
électeurs de l'aspect extrêmement
déformé selon les départements les gens
ne reprendront pas le même nombre
d'électeurs moi je suis en République
déjà on peut discuter du fait est-ce que
il y a deux chambres et puis surtout
cette idée d'une telle distorsion selon
les territoires de la représentation est
quand même très discutable mais au-delà
de ça moi
je souhaite à ce que les grandes
électeurs fassent entendre notamment
voilà une préférence sur le programme
que nous portons mais je suis pas pour
mettre en œuvre je peux vous dire comme
ça
dépend des départements je vais pas
raconter d'histoires nous sommes une
force à l'occasion de la vie
parlementaire la vie présidentielle on
avait fait des choix aux élections
municipales qui amènent à ce que nous
n'avons pas nous avons moins d'élus
municipaux mais il peut y avoir chez les
grands électeurs aussi une volonté de
dire c'est pas bien qu'on n'est pas pu
faire des listes du peste mais pour
conclure le sur ce point moi je ne veux
pas alimenter la machine à division de
la nuit pèse je suis favorable à l'année
du pèse j'aimerais qu'on arrive aux
élections européennes à avoir une liste
commune je pense que ce serait bien ce
serait propulsif pour les chances
présidentielles qui suit en 2027 on
pourrait virer en tête la France
insoumise se prépare à avoir sa propre
liste
chaque chose non mais ça on peut pas
être absent d'un débat européen mais
vous m'invitez au mois de septembre si
vous me faites le plaisir et l'honneur
de me réinviter dans quelques mois on
tire à le bilan pour l'instant j'utilise
ma parole médiatique pour dire pourquoi
faisons liste commune pourquoi parce que
cette élection européenne et moins
structurante évidemment que l'élection
présidentielle ou se joue vraiment le
pouvoir toutefois elle peut avoir un
côté dynamique dans un moment
particulier si j'en crois les sondages
le ce qui nous disent que la force
politique qui marche devant c'est
l'extrême droite suivi de peu par le
parti gouvernemental pourtant s'il est
crié
nouveaux partenaires de gauche il dit
c'est une élections on aura plus de
détails
de toute manière la France insoumise ne
va pas disparaître dans ce scrutin non
mais vous mais je veux une liste commune
et j'aimerais qu'on puisse y arriver
peut-être ça peut se voir vous êtes pas
le seul Jean-Luc Mélenchon aussi mais
vous parlez de vos amis communistes
socialiste écologiques vous avez entendu
Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur BFM dimanche qui
dit très clairement je n'aime pas il dit
je il dit qu'il n'aime pas ses
partenaires de la nuque il dit que les
écologistes font du jardinage je cite
que les socialistes sont mignons ce
week-end Mathilde pano et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon on dira boulet rouge sur
Fabien Roussel qui n'est plus un
camarade qu'est-ce qu'il reste de tout
ça c'est encore possible d'avoir une
union dans ces conditions là faut il y
avait c'est la bonne gardienne
est-ce qu'il aurait dû dire la nuque je
les aime pas mais moi
j'utilise pas mon temps médiatique pour
venir dire du mal des ans et des autres
en plus là vous me demandez
non mais vous me demandez de juger
y compris des camarades etc chacun
avance
quand même pardon ça perturbe le jeu
c'est difficile il y a bâtir une
alliance dans des nouveaux volants
l'unité il la faut à l'occasion des
élections européennes voilà on peut dire
différentes manières de le dire il le
faut pas seulement
meilleur moyen d'avoir l'unité mais il
s'agit il faut y arriver voilà ce que je
dis aux uns et aux autres arrêtons le
jeu des des propos pour exister etc on
sortait d'une fête de l'Humanité ou
toute une série de propos avec tenu par
les en période mais moi j'ai même pas
envie de de je m'en fous la vie
politique je voulais dire avant que vous
me coupiez que il y avait un lit dans
les années 70 qui disait l'Union étant
combat je combats là-dedans mais pour
convaincre pourquoi il faut l'Union pas
pour se faire plaisir mais parce que
nous sommes dans un moment inédit de la
vie politique depuis 1945 l'extrême
droite est extrêmement puissante à un
tel point qu'il est possible qu'elle
prenne le pouvoir alors soit on
considère que l'extrême droite est une
force communautante et qu'après tout
c'est pas grave voire même comme l'a dit
le président du Ménès c'est peut-être un
mal dont nous avons besoin ce que je ne
crois pas parce que je pense que si
Madame Le Pen prend le pouvoir dans ce
pays nous rentrons dans une nouvelle
phase politique particulière qui fera
mal au mouvement social qui amènera à ce
qu'il y ait une situation de tension et
d'affrontement quasi de guerre civile
dans certains endroits parce que je vois
bien mécanique qui se met à noble donc
je ne veux pas ça et je lance un signal
d'alerte pour dire nous nous sommes
souvent affrontés les uns les autres
avant 2022 en particulier mais nous
sommes rentrés depuis juin 2022 dans une
nouvelle étape celle de la nécessaire
union dans le parce que nous pensons que
dans une tripolarisation de la vie
politique aujourd'hui notre camp social
écologique et démocratique et plus fort
s'il est rassemblé je ne veux pas lâcher
cela
nuque mais sans emporter la
responsabilité alors pour quelle raison
arrêtez de mettre ça sur le dos de
seulement de Jean-Luc Mélenchon comme si
c'était ça le sujet le sujet vous l'avez
dit tout à pourquoi le raison au
sénateurs réussi à seulement faire en
sorte que la France insoumise soit
représenté pourquoi nous n'arrivons pas
à ce que aux élections européennes nous
ayons liste commune donc mon problème il
est comment dire de revenir peut-être
c'est pour ça que je rappelais la la
façon dont l'excellente aujourd'hui
c'est installé dans le paysage la
décomposition de la droite
traditionnelle enfin je veux dire
l'événement important que je vois c'est
que Madame Pécresse à l'occasion la
dernière avec son présidentielle fait
moins de 5% que Monsieur Darmanin dont
vous parlez tout à l'heure qui se
voulait être un champion peut-être de
l'après Macron etc et sonder dans les
instituts de sondages à peine au-dessus
de 10%. donc c'est il y a une
décomposition de de y compris des
secteurs de la droite qui sont sans
doute en train d'être plus polarisé par
l'extrême droite donc je dis tyrans-en
des conclusions stratégiques et ne nous
tirons pas dessus tirons des conclusions
et pas des annathèmes donc et de ce
point de vue là je regrette parfois de
voir Fabien Roussel en rajouter beaucoup
et être très persuadé qu'il faut
absolument qu'il aille tout seul dans
son coin avec son présidentielle je
trouve que là-dessus il manque un peu de
de compréhension du moment et j'invite à
ce que chacun est toutes les directions
politiques se disent comment on fait en
sorte que nous restions Unis malgré
après des tas de difficultés nous sommes
rassemblés sur un programme celui de la
nupes qui a un caractère dynamique il
est assez complet il répond à la
situation défendons ça unité et moi je
ne serai je ne soutiendrai pas on entend
pas
un colloque sur la République
231 ans de la programmation de la
République quand Elisabeth borne dit que
les insoumis sont pas dans l'arc
républicain savoir non mais je veux dire
déjà un paradoxe c'est que tout le monde
parle de République aujourd'hui la
droite même s'appelle les républicains
plus républicain combat tumeur et demain
21 septembre 21 septembre 1792 date
quasiment effacées de nos agendas c'est
un peu curieux d'ailleurs qu'est-ce
qu'il y a d'intéressant à retenir du 21
septembre 1792 que c'est dans le fracas
une grande révolution populaire pour la
première fois on entre en République et
on pose la question qui se traduit dans
la Constitution 1793 d'un état social et
démocratique ça ça m'intéresse ça reste
vraiment d'actualité et ça nous dit quoi
que la République elle n'est pas neutre
notamment sur des questions sociales
donc ce que je veux fêter demain en
faisant ce colloque fêter avec des
historiens c'est ça deuxièmement
l'utilisation abusive par certains vous
avez pointé madame bord du mot
républicain qui perd totalement de sens
la République c'est pas les compagnies
républicaines de sécurité c'est pas que
ça c'est une idée sociale de partage
démocratique et l'ultra les anciennes
Bonaparte de la Cinquième République de
mon point de vue tourne le dos à la
promesse républicaine qui était celle de
la lutte contre le pouvoir personnel
c'est pour ça que la République est née
contre l'ancien régime là il y a vous là
demain il y a trois discuter et
s'inspirer peut-être pour la suite
dernière question aujourd'hui on a
Charlotte III roi d'Angleterre qui vient
chez nous le dîner ce soir à Versailles
dans la galerie des glaces et c'est pas
un peu tout match pour vous c'est alors
je vais prendre des choses moi je trouve
bien qu'il y ait de l'amitié
franco-britannique et franchement
que en haut personnage anglais aime la
France quoi qu'il aime le Bordelais il
connaît bien la France pour qu'il parle
français etc donc bienvenue mais après
l'utilisation abusive de la part
d'Emmanuel Macron de tous les artifices
y compris d'anciens régimes et
Versailles en veux-tu en voilà et
j'accueille Poutine à Versailles bon moi
au bout d'un moment c'est un peu la même
chose je fais le lien avec avec la messe
du pape attention dans ce pays il y a
des choses qui sont symboliques quand à
force on a l'impression que mais il
avait théorisé Emmanuel Macron qui aura
un grand vide dans l'histoire politique
depuis il avait dit depuis qu'on a
tranché la tête du roi il y a un vide
dans le cherche il y a un absent de la
vie politique en sous-entendu le
monarque et il veut lui investir ça je
pense qu'il a tort je suis en désaccord
avec l'utilisation abusive qui fait de
l'ultra présidentialisme et de ce ce
comment dirais-je se tiret du col pour
accueillir Charles III dans le cadre
quand même qui était l'ancien régime
ceci dit Charles III et vive la France
et vive l'amitié franco-britaine